[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wenn im jeddischen gesagt wird jemand
sei am Mensch dann ist damit ja so viel
mehr gemeint mensch das ist ein eine
Person die anständig ist empathisch das
Herz auf dem rechten Fleck hat human im
besten Sinne des Wortes am mensch das
ist ein guter Mensch dieser für Juden
und Jüdinnen weltweit so vertraute
Begriff stand im Zentrum der Rede die
der Journalist Marcel Reif heute im
Bundestag hielt neben der
91-Jährigen Eva zpesi die als Kind in
Auschwitz war ihre Erinnerungen und die
Worte von Marcel Reif als Sohn eines
Überlebenden prägten diese sehr
besondere Gedenkstunde im Parlament
davon berichtet Frank
Buchwald der Bundestag hält inne ans
Rednerpult tritt Eva sepesi als Mädchen
verschleppt aus Budapest nach Auschwitz
sie überlebt krank in einer Baracke für
todgehalten dann die Erlösung als mein
Blick langsam klarer wurde erkannte ich
einen russischen
Soldaten der sich lächelnd über mich
beugte die menschliche Wärme in seinem
Blick tat mir gut es war der 27 januar
1945 und ich
lebte heute erschreckt sie neuer
Antisemitismus Terror in Israel das habe
ihr Leben verändt
Deut deshalb eine
mnung began nicht mit
Auschwitz sie begann mit Worten sie
begann mit dem Schweigen und dem
wegschauen der Gesellschaft und jetzt
stehe ich hier im
Bundestag um Zeugnis
abzulegen es war nie wichtiger als jetzt
denn nie wieder ist
jetzt Marcel Reif der bekannte
Sportjournalist berichtet von seinem
Vater auch er überlebte die Schoa und
schwieg kein Wort über all das was er
erlebt was er überlebt hatte er sprach
nicht und ich fragte nicht es durfte
nicht sein dass auch noch seine Kinder
von den furchtbaren Schatten heimgesucht
gequält werden die seine Kindheit und
Jugend verdunkelt zerstört hatten wir
sollten wir durften nicht in jedem
Postboten bcker in jedem
Straßenbahnfahrer oder Lehrer einen
möglichen Mörder unser großaltern
vermuten nie wieder sei kein Appell
sondern Verpflichtung und reif zitiert
das Vermächtnis seines Vaters drei Worte
nur und wenn sie es mirlauben und wenn
Sie mögen gerade heute aus diesem Anlass
und gerade hier in diesem höchsten
deutschen
Hause dann lasse ich Ihnen den kleinen
und doch so großartigen wundervollen
Satz den mein Vater Leon reif gesagt hat
dann lasse ich ihn diesen Satz hier sei
ein Mensch sei ein
Mensch ein Mensch zu bleiben auch wenn
man sich streitet und miteinander
konkurriert ist für uns Menschen ja e
eine Herausforderung nicht bßhaft zu
werden auch beim schärfsten
Schlagabtausch das gelingt oft nicht ist
aber ja eigentlich auch das was einer
parlamentarischen Demokratie zugrunde
liegen sollte Streit aber nicht Hass
fair bleiben auch gegenüber den
politischen Gegner wenn nötig auch
kooperieren zu können aber an diesem
Ideal orientieren sich wohl nicht alle
im Bundestag eine Debatte gab es dort
heute nämlich auch die Generaldebatte in
der haushaltswoche ein parlamentar
Klassiker TRS hat dazu
gehört die Generaldebatte das erste
Rededuell von Oppositionsführer und
Kanzler in diesem Jahr Friedrich März
übt Fundamentalkritik an der Regierung
die Ampel mache eine so schlechte
wirtschaftssozial und Klimapolitik da
lohne es nicht mal eigene Anträge der
Union in die Haushaltsberatung
einzubringen so grundlegend die
Unterschiede wenn Sie die Jacke unten
falsch einknöpfen dann diskutieren wir
nicht mit ihnen wie groß denn der Knopf
oben im letzten Loch sein sollte diese
Diskussion führen wir mit ihnen nicht
ganz einfach MZ klingt nicht nach
Zusammenarbeit oder deutschlandpakt der
Kanzler auch nicht auffallend
kämpferisch tritt er auf er wird
persönlich eine Mimose nennt er den
unionsfraktionschef und wirft ihm vor
Gespräche zur Migration abgebrochen zu
haben so eine hasenfüßigkeit vor der
eigenen Verantwortung davon laufen das
habe ich noch nicht erlebt Herr
[Applaus]
noehen aggressiv die Rede der AFD Chefin
die ampelziehe eine Schneise der
Verwüstung durchs Land ohne Rücksicht
auf die arbeitende Bevölkerung sie
können Deutschland nicht gut regieren
und sie wollen es nicht sie richten es
Zug Grunde und ich sag ihn auch
warum weil sie ihr eigenes Land weil sie
Deutschland hassen diese Regierung
des Union und Ampel scheint klar gegen
Rechtsextremismus müssen sie
zusammenstehen weidels Breitseite gegen
die etablierten Parteien sie ein
Opposition und Regierung zumindest für
den
Moment ihre
Einlassung diese Regierung hasst
Deutschland die ist mit aller Schärfe
zurückzuweisen dies diese Regierung
regiert schlecht aber sie HST dieses
Land
nicht Achtung wie viel
Menschenfeindlichkeit wie viel
Gefährlichkeit und wie viel
Verächtlichmachung demokratischer
Institutionen waren hier gerade in 10
Minuten zu hören die Liberalen machen
der Wahl klar sie halten an der
Schuldenbremse fest auf offener Bühne
mahnen sie Grüne und SPD erst recht nach
dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil daran nicht zu
rütteln bedeutet aber lieber Rolf Mütze
nicht nicht dass wir die Schuldenbremse
umgehen dieses Urteil bedeutet auch
nicht dass wir die Schuldenbremse
Schleifen sondern dieses Urteil bedeutet
dass wir die Schuldenbremse in diesem
Land Stärken lieber Rolf für diesen
Appell kein Applaus der SPD aber von der
Union der Streit innerhalb der Ampel
wird andauern auch macht die Debatte
klar märz und Scholz sind unversöhnlich
unterwegs und die Auseinandersetzung mit
der AFD wird das kommende Wahljahr
dominieren
auch bei dieser Bundestagsdebatte wurde
deutlich dass es weiterhin vor allem das
migrationsthema ist das Populisten nährt
und diejenigen die politische
Verantwortung tragen treibt da man bei
den Grundfragen der Flüchtlingspolitik
auf andere Länder angewiesen ist und im
Alleingang vergleichsweise wenig
gestalten kann versuchen Bund und Länder
an den Stellschrauben zu drehen die
verfügbar sind so soll jetzt für
geflüchtete und Asylbewerber die
sogenannte Bezahlkarte bundesweit
eingeführt werden 14 der 16 Bundesländer
haben sich dazu heute auf gemeinsame
Standards geeinigt Bayern und
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wollen ebenfalls
Karten einführen aber mit eigenen
Modellen in manchen Kommunen gibt es sie
bereits etwa in Thüringen von dort
berichtet Anna
buchschwelter Lebensmittel für die
Familie wenn Asylbewerberin erinda Latza
im thüringischen worbes einkauft zahlt
sie nicht mehr bar sondern mit der
Bezahlkarte des
Landkreises für mich macht das keinen
Unterschied ich muss im Supermarkt
einkaufen brauche Kleidung die Dinge
fürs tägliche
Leben seit Dezember läuft der
Modellversuch im eigsfeld einer von zwei
in Thüringen rund die Hälfte der
Leistungen Bucht der Landkreis den
Asylbewerbern auf die Karte nun sollen
solche Bezahlkarten bundesweit
eingeführt werden die Länder haben sich
auf einheitliche Standards geeinigt
suchen jetzt einen Dienstleister
dafür aus meiner Sicht wird die Karte
wirklich ein ganz wichtiger Beitrag dazu
sein a die Anreize zu senken B den
Missbrauch zu verhindern und B
insbesondere das schleuserwesens zu
stoppen Humanität ist wichtig aber
gleichzeitig dürfen wir auch nicht naiv
sein und wenn wir unser Sozialsystem in
diesem Sinne weiter aufrechterhalten
wollen wenn wir weiterhin Menschen die
Schutz suchen diesen Schutz gewähren
wollen d müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
ein Missbrauch unterbleibt die
Bezahlkarte soll funktionieren wie eine
Guthabenkarte ohne Konto bezahlen kann
man damit grundsätzlich überall wo auch
EC-Karten angenommen werden was nicht
geht Überweisungen ins Inn und Ausland
und die Bundesländer könnten die Karten
sogar noch weiter beschränken z.B
regional nach Postleitzahl der Thüringer
Flüchtlingsrat kritisiert das ganze
Modell und das hat mit der Würde der
Menschen nicht zu tun wenn Sie
nichtleich behandelt werden wie alle
Menschen in dieser Gesellschaft da
würden sie diskriminiert im eigsfeld
dagegen sieht der Landrat sein Projekt
als Erfolg denn es soll zusätzlich zum
Arbeiten anregen wer hier einen Job
annimmt bekommt die Leistungen wieder in
bar der Effekt 55 Asylbewerber sind
gegangen 17 arbeiten jetzt sagt Werner
Henning das ist für uns vielleicht das
allerwichtigste zu sagen Flüchtlinge ihr
müsst zur Kenntnis nehmen dass wir nicht
mehr in der Lage sind rund um Quartiere
und Service in all der gewünschten Form
zu schaffen bitte nehmt euer Leben
selbst in die Hand und Leben in die Hand
nehmen heißt Arbeiten voraussichtlich ab
Sommer sollen die Bezahlkarten
bundesweit eingeführt werden nur bei der
Vergabe wollen Bayern und Mecklenburg
vor Pommern eigene Wege
gehen zu dem Thema gibt es nachher im
heute journal Update noch ein Gespräch
mit brandenburgs Ministerpräsident
Dietmar wolg mit dem Blick auf den den
deutschen Arbeitsmarkt geht es bei dir
jetzt weits die Zahl der Arbeitslosen in
Deutschland ist im Januar gestiegen
allerdings geringer als sonst zum
Jahreswechsel üblich die Vorsitzende der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit nales sagte der
Arbeitsmarkt zeige sich zu Jahresbeginn
trotz Wirtschaftsschwäche stabil laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit waren im Januar
2805000 Menschen auf Jobsuche das sind
169 000 mehr als im Dezember die Quote
stieg auf
6,1% gegenüber dem Januar des Vorjahres
stieg die Zahl der Arbeitslosen um
000 der frühere
Verfassungsschutzpräsident marßen ist
selbst ins Visier seiner ehemaligen
Behörde geraten der Verfassungsschutz
soll marßen im nachrichtlichen
nachrichtendienstlichen
Informationssystem im Bereich
Rechtsextremismus abgespeichert haben
nach ZDF Informationen liegt eine
umfangreiche Materialsammlung zu Maßen
vor er selbst sei bereits vor zwei
Wochen informiert worden Maren schrieb
auf der Plattform x die Auskunft des
Verfassungsschutzes enthalte keinerlei
substantiierte Belege die eine
Beobachtung
rechtfertigten die EU-Kommission will
eine umweltschutzauflage für Landwirte
lockern rückwirken zum 1 Januar soll die
Regel ausgesetzt werden wonach 4% des
Ackerlandes brach liegen oder
unproduktiv genutzt werden müssen das SE
eine erste konkrete politische Antwort
auf einkommensprobleme von Landwirten so
die Kommission wie hier in Frankreich
forderten auch heute Bauern in mehreren
europäischen Ländern weniger Bürokratie
und bessere Preise für ihre Produkte bei
der Besetzung eines Großmarktes bei
Paris nahm die Polizei mindestens 79
Menschen in
gewahsam Außenministerin bbock hat von
den Vereinten Nationen eine rasche
Aufklärung der Vorwürfe gegen mehrere
Mitarbeiter des palästinenserhilfswerkes
ein RWA gefordert sie werden beschuldigt
an den hamasterrorakten in Israel am 7
Oktober beteiligt gewesen zu sein
mehrere westliche Länder haben die
Zahlungen an die UNRWA vorübergehend
eingestellt darunter die USA und
Deutschland un- Generalsekretär
guteresch versprach umfassende
Aufklärung und betonte die Bedeutung des
Hilfswerkes für die Versorgung der
Menschen im
Gasastreifen die Marin missission der EU
im Roten Meer soll in etwa drei Wochen
beginnen bis dahin wird ein formeller
Beschluss dazu erwartet wie es nach
einem Verteidigungsminister treffen hieß
vorgesehen ist dass mehrere europäische
Kriegsschiffe und Flugzeuge
bereitgestellt werden zum Schutz von
Frachtschiffen vor Angriffen der
militanten huti aus dem
Jemen Russland und die Ukraine haben
erneut Kriegsgefangene ausgetauscht von
beiden Seiten konnten jeweils etwa 200
Menschen zurück in ihre Heimat nach
ukrainischen Angaben war es bereits der
50 Austausch seit Beginn der russischen
Invasion insgesamt seien so bereits über
3000 Ukrainer freigekommen dabeil
meldete die Ukraine über Nacht erneut
russischen Beschuss mit Drohnen und
Raketen zu den bitteren Beobachtungen
dieses Krieges gehört auch wie
ausgemärgelt und misshandelt viele
ukrainische Kriegsgefangene aus den
russischen Lagern zurückkehren der weil
die EU Verteidigungsminister heute
eingestehen mussten dass sie nicht
ansatzweise in der Lage sind der Ukraine
so viele Artilleriegeschosse zu liefern
wie sie vor knapp einem Jahr versprochen
hatten bei der Frage wie die Europäer
die Ukraine unterstützen hat sich aber
immerhin die Rolle der deutschen und
deren Wahrnehmung gründlich geändert
seinen Bericht dazu beginnt Floria
Neuhann mit einem Blick
zurück der Auftritt der Deutschlands
Image in diesem Krieg lange prägt ist
fast auf den Tag zi Jahre her die die
Ministerin von damals ist Geschichte ihr
Stolz im Rückblick noch
kurioser wir werden 5000 Helme an die
Ukraine liefern auch als ganz deutliches
Signal wir stehen an eurer Seite
Deutschland muss getrieben werden die
Rolle auf die scholzreierung fortan
festgelegt ist zwei Jahre später die
Ukraine kommt nicht voran Olaf Scholz
hat für sich eine neue Rolle gefunden
die des
antreibers es muss unser Beitrag sein
dass wir viel tun aber es muss auch der
Beitrag aller anderen sein auch viel zu
tun auf den ersten Blick geben die
Zahlen Scholz Recht nach den USA steht
Deutschland bei der militärischen Hilfe
an zweiter Stelle weit vor großen
EU-Partnern wie Italien oder Frankreich
ein ungewohnter Platz für Deutschland
heute in Brüssel beim Treffen der
Verteidigungsminister
ungewohntes
Lob das ist eine großartige
Führungsrolle die Deutschland im Moment
spielt doch wie das so ist mit den
Zahlen wer will kann genauso das
Gegenteil belegen setzt man die
militärische Hilfe ins Verhältnis zur
eigenen Wirtschaftskraft landet
Deutschland nur noch auf Platz 9
abgeschlagen hinter Estland litaauen
Lettland aber vor den USA Italien oder
Frankreich sicherlich hat Deutschland
viel mehr gemacht über diese letzten
zwei Jahre aber
ob das genug ist äh
um die Ukraine in den kommenden Monaten
und
Jahren zu unterstützen
und einen Sieg ukrainischen Sieg zu
ermöglichen das ist halt fraglich was
ist genug heute stellen Europas
verteidigungsministerinnen und Minister
erstmal offiziell fest wie deutlich sie
ihr eigenes versprechen verfehlen die
Zusage nämlich bis März eine Million
Geschosse an die Ukraine zu liefern
erreichen wird Europa nur die Hälfte den
Rest erst bis Ende dieses Jahres und
Europas außenbeauftragter wird zum
Beauftragten fürs schön
ren ich denke wir sollten recht
zufrieden sein mit dem was wir erreicht
haben tatsächlich haben wir der Ukraine
ja über eine halbe Million Geschosse
übergeben europa müsse deutlich mehr tun
Kontern fünf EU Regierungschefs heute
schriftlich darunter der deutsche
Kanzler ein Appell den Scholz und Co an
den EU-Gipfel von morgen richten ein
Appell also irgendwie auch an sich
selbst vier Jahre ist es nun schon her
dass Großbritannien förmlich aus der EU
ausgetreten ist nach langem Ach und
Krach schon die populistisch geführte
brexit Kampagne hatte das Vereinigte
Königreich an den Rand einer Spaltung
getrieben und den anderen Europäern
manch Einblicke in die britische Seele
gewehrt die vorsichtig gesag sagt
irritierend waren im Land selbst
zerbrachen an der aufgeheizten Debatte
teils ganze Familien und
Freundschaften auch deshalb rühren
britische Politiker auch die der
Opposition am liebsten gar nicht mehr an
dem Thema der brexit ist wie der Elefant
im Raum man sieht ihn aber man spricht
lieber nicht darüber wie es den Britten
vier Jahre danach geht und was sie
darüber denken berichtet unsere
Korrespondentin Hilke
Petersen Countdown ins brexit Glück
[Applaus]
das war vor genau 4 Jahren da war
Großbritannien raus aus der EU quälende
Verhandlungen
vorbei heute am selben Ort vor dem
Parlament da stehen die brexit Gegner
seit Jahren und drehen die Europahymne
auf wenn der Premierminister
vorbeifährt Euphorie das war gestern
vier Jahre danach brexit
Wirklichkeit
wie sehr der Alltag von brexit
beeinflusst ist von den Geldbörsen bis
hin zur Freizügigkeit die Leute haben
das jetzt
realisiert die steigenden
Lebensmittelpreise belasten die Leute am
meisten macht die Lebenshaltungskosten
insgesamt total
unerträglich daran hat der brexit
entscheidenden Anteil viele Briten sind
ärmer im Durchschnitt um mehr als 2000 €
im vergangenen Jahr weil brexit ihre
Kosten hochtreibt eine Studie des
Londoner Bürgermeister es rechnet vor 2
Millionen Jobs weniger quer durchs Land
auf dem Londoner Großmarkt brauchen sie
starke Nerven neue Importkontrollen
gelten seit heute für tierische Produkte
Gemüse und Pflanzen die aus der EU
kommen fünfm hatte die Regierung das
bereits
verschoben die Unsicherheit die hat mir
viele schlaflose Nächte beschert in den
letzten Jahren wegen des brexit und all
seiner Kosten bis hin zu dem Punkt wo
wir abwägen mussten ob es sinnvoll ist
weiterzu
[Musik]
machen ab heute also mehr zollbürokratie
für unterschiedliche Produktklassen das
muss sitzen damit es an der Grenze nicht
länger
dauert bei jedem kleinen Fehler in neun
von Z Fällen liegt es eher an der
Regierung als an uns aber wir sind am
Ende immer diejenigen die darunter
leiden bei der wöchentlichen Fragestunde
mit dememminister he sind vi Jahre
brexit kein Thema besser nicht erwähnen
denn die nächste Wahl steht
an und weitere Checks ab April von LKW
Ladungen etwa nach Ankunft im faerhafen
von Dover Bilder möglicher Staus machen
sich auch schlecht bei britischen
Wählern fragt man die heute ob sie
wieder eintreten wollten in die EU sagen
51% ja viele andere bleiben offenbar bei
ihrer
Meinung
und mit der wirtschaftlichen Lage in
Deutschland geht's jetzt bei dir weiter
die Inflation in Deutschland ist zu
Jahresbeginn deutlich zurückgegangen die
Verbraucherpreise stiegen im Januar nur
noch um
2,9% so die vorläufigen Daten des
Statistischen Bundesamtes Valerie Haller
woher kommt die inflationsbremse das hat
verschiedene Gründe einer davon ist die
wirtschaftliche Schwäche die Sparquote
ist hoch Verbraucher halten ihr Geld
zusammen zum leitwesen des Einzelhandels
ja und da haben es Unternehmen eben
schwer höhere Preise durchzusetzen ja
und ein weiterer Grund sind die
niedrigeren Energiepreise vor allem
Strom und Gas sind günstiger geworden
Energie kostete im Januar
2,8% weniger als ein Jahr zuvor
Lebensmittel hingegen bleiben
Preistreiber sie wurden
3,8% teurer die Inflationsrate insgesamt
liegt inzwischen so niedrig wie seit
2021 nicht mehr und nähert sich in
Richtung des Ziels der Europäischen
Zentralbank und das liegt bei glatt
2% und wie sind die Prognosen wie geht's
mit der Inflation weiter ökonomen gehen
davon aus dass die Preise dieses Jahr
wenn auch langsamer weiter zurückgehen
werden gänzlich gebannt ist das
Inflationsrisiko aber noch nicht ein
Hinweis darauf sind die aktuell harten
Tarifauseinandersetzungen die Löhne
könnten also für weiteren Preisauftrieb
sorgen übrigens auch die amerikanische
Notenbank beobachtet die dortige
Inflation weiter mit Vorsicht wie heute
bekannt wurde die Fett die Zinsen
unangetastet die Zinswende lässt also
auch dort noch auf sich warten werie
Haller vielen
Dank morgen werden bundesweit
voraussichtlich mehr als 1100 Flüge
ausfallen oder verspätet stattfinden
weil die Gewerkschaft werdi das
Sicherheitspersonal an elf größeren
deutschen Flughäfen zum eintägigen
Warnstreik aufgerufen hat am Flughafen
Köln Bonn hat der Streik bereits am
Abend begonnen wie hier in Hamburg
wurden auch an den flugh hfen Berlin
Hannover und Stuttgart für morgen alle
Abflüge gestrichen die
Fluggesellschaften versuchen Reisende
umzubuchen am Drehkreuz Frankfurt wird
nur umsteigen im Transitbereich möglich
sein und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr 11 24 28 29 40 43 und die
Superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahen finden
Sie auf lotte. zdfde und im ZDF Text auf
Seite
557 die weltsommerspiele der Special
Olympics letztes Jahr in Berlin waren ja
ein voller Erfolg viel Aufmerksamkeit in
den Medien jede Menge Zuschauer und die
freiwilligen Helfer die sogenannten
volonteers schwärmten nachher von der
tollen
Atmosphäre das hat sich offenbar
herumgesprochen denn bei den nationalen
Winterspielen jetzt in Thüringen konnten
sich die Veranstalter kaum vor lauter
Freiwilligen die sich als volteers
bewarben um bei der Organisation zu
helfen und Athleten mit Einschränkungen
zu unterstützen zu tun gibt es für sie
eine Menge aber vor allem auch eine
Menge Spaß mon trebing beobachtet
hat mit vollem Eifer sind sie dabei
machen Stimmung für jede und jeden
einzelnen Athleten ein eigenes
Empfangskomitee alles machen damit die
Leute sich freuen sich wohlühn am Ziel
ankommen wir wollen unbedingt dabei sein
wir wollen helfen und die Atmosphäre ist
auch ganz fantastisch unter uns als
Gruppe aber auch hier ist es herrlich
ohne Helferinnen und Helfer ist so ein
Event wie die Special Olympics nicht zu
stemmen 500 von ihnen sind täglich da
unterstützen feuern an stoppen Zeiten
haben alles im Blick genug helfende
Hände finden bei den Spielen der
vergangenen Jahre nicht immer so einfach
diesmal gab es einen regelrechten Run
viele wollten unbedingt dabei
sein wir hatten das große Glück nach den
Special Olympics World Games im Sommer
in Berlin eine große Anzahl an Bewerbung
zu erhalten für die Helferinnen und
Helfer und hatten dadurch ja das Glück
dass wir aus dem Vollen schöpfen konnten
und hatten tatsächlich 1200 Bewerbung
mehr als der Hälfte mussten sie Absagen
ein Novum ein Zeichen für Inklusion im
Sport Berührungsängste abbauen
miteinander Spaß haben für die vielen
helfenden ein Antrieb ich habe selbst
Behinderung und kenne quasi die
Herausforderung die man dann oft
irgendwie begegnet und finde das total
schön den Menschen irgendwas zu
ermöglichen was zur Teilhabe an der
Gesellschaft beiträgt aus ganz
Deutschland kommen die Freiwilligen um
hier dabei zu sein einige werden von
ihren Arbeitgebern freigestellt viele
nehmen sich extra Urlaub um den
Sportlerinnen und Sportlern die Special
Olympics zu ermöglichen die Leute sind
so toll so herzlich ja auch wenn jemand
verliert die lachen die freuen und da
habe ich gesagt ich mit die ersten Tage
erfolgreich geschafft gemeinsam stark
noch bis Freitag treten sie alle an für
Ihre ganz persönlichen Erfolge jeden Tag
mit vollem
[Applaus]
Eifer das war's von uns gleich geht's
mit dem auslandjournal weiter da gibt es
unter anderem eine Reportage von gline
atai die zwei Wochen lang durch den
Jemen gereist ist und um 0:30 Uhr gibt
es dann unser heute Schal Update mit
Christopher wermann wir melden uns
morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend diese
eindrucksvolle tiefdruckspirale brachte
schon heute Windgeschwindigkeiten von
mehr als 150 km pro Stunde also
orkanböhnen und heute Nacht werden hier
so zwischen Trondheim und Bodö durchaus
Orkanböhen bis 200 km pro Stunde
auftreten gleichzeitig werden innerhalb
von 36 Stunden 1 m Neuschnee in den
norwegischen Bergen fallen das ist das
Tief Margret und dieses Tief Margret
wird auch uns beschäftigen mit seiner
Kaltfront die zieht nämlich heute Nacht
und morgen über Tag südostwärts weg dann
kommt schon gleich das nächste Tief und
dieses Hoch Frank wird uns wohl bis in
die nächste Woche begleiten jetzt
begleitet uns erstmal der Regen der
Feldt heute Nacht zwischen der Ostsee
und der Mosel am Alpenrand ist es
dagegen klar so sinken die Temperaturen
in Bayern auf +3 bis -1° sonst bleibt
die Nacht bei 7 bis 3° milder die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen recht
einheitlich zwischen 6 und 11° und am
Vormittag wird's vor allen Dingen in der
Mitte und im Süden noch länger trüb sein
mit Regen im Norden lockern die Wolken
schon auf be einem starken zum Teil
stürmischen Wind aus westlichen
Richtungen an der Ostsee dort kann es
dann am Nachmittag noch für einige
Regenschauer reichen sonst wird das ein
freundlicher Nachmittag am Oberrhein und
auch im alpenforland gibt's noch weitere
regenfäer sehr wechselhaft geht's dann
in den nächsten Tagen und auch zum
Wochenende noch weiter das liegt daran
dass wir genau zwischen einem Tief über
Skandinavien und einem hoch über der
iberischen Halbinsel liegen guten Abend